DEAL THAT WOULD BANKRUPT
AMERICA.
MORE ON THE MEDIA HYPOCRISY
LATER.
FIRST JOINING US WITH REACTION
IS THE HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN McCARTY.
LET'S START WITH SXHIF.
-- SCHIFF.
YOU BELIEVE HE MET HIS OWN
STANDARD AS IT RELATES TO
RECUSAL IN THE INVESTIGATION.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION IS NOT
GOING THE WAY HE WANTS.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
SCHIFF LAID OUT THAT ANYBODY
THAT SHOWS A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST OR DISBELIEF HAS TO
RECUSE THEMSELVES.
SCHIFF, WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO
FIND OUT WHO PAID FOR THE
DOSSIER.
IT WAS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT
PAID THE RUSSIAN FOR THE
DOSSIER.
SCHIFF MET WITH GLENN SIMPSON
THE CO-FOUNDER OF FUSION GPS.
AND NELLIE OHR THE WIFE OF OHR
AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
AT THE TIME HE MET WITH HIM, THE
COMMITTEE WANTED TO RELOOK AT
HIM BECAUSED ON THE TESTIMONY
GLENN SIMPSON HAD GIVEN.
DID SCHIFF TALK TO SIMPSON ABOUT
THAT?
NOW WITH MICHAEL COHEN SCHIFF
TALKED TO HIM.
DID STAFF MEET WITH HIM?
DID HE TAMPER WITH THE WITNESS?
>> Sean: THEY TALKED ABOUT
ISSUES WOULD COME UP?
>> SCHIFF HASN'T SAID SO.
THESE ARE QUESTIONS HE NEEDS TO
ANSWER.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS
INTERESTING.
WHEN GLENN SIMPSON CAME BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE, SCHIFF AT THE END
ASKED SIMPSON TO DIRECT THE
COMMITTEE ON WHERE THEY SHOULD
WITH THE INVESTIGATION.
THEN THE MOST OUTRAGEOUS THING
IN THE MICHAEL COHEN HEARING.
WHILE THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
IS GOING FORWARD.
THIS WHOLE THING OF COLLUSION.
IF IT'S BASED ON THE BELIEF THAT
MICHAEL COHEN WENT TO PRAGUE TO
MEET WITH THE RUSSIANS.
MICHAEL COHEN SAID HE DID NOT.
THE FOUNDATION FOR WHY WE ARE
EVEN IN THE INVESTIGATION HAS
BEEN THROWN APART.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN, WHAT DID
YOU THINK OF THE TAPE I JUST
PLAYED?
IN THAT TAPE, ADAM SCHIFF
BELIEVED HE WAS TALKING TO A
RUSSIAN OPERATIVE WITH
COMPROMISING MATERIAL ON DONALD
TRUMP.
IT SOUNDED LIKE COLLUSION TO DIG
UP DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP.
>> SCHIFF, BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION EVEN BEGAN, HE
SAID HE HAS PROOF AND EVIDENCE.
SCHIFF IS A NOD MODERN-DAY
McCARTH WHO CLAIMS SOMETHING AND
NEVER DELIVERS ON.
-- HE PROTECTED GLENN.
>> Sean: THEY ARE GOING TO USE
UP TO 8 HOUSE COMMITTEES NOW.
NON-STOP INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS THE WIDEST NET
INVESTIGATION WE HAVE EVER SEEN.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
THIS IS LIKE MODERN-DAY
McCARTYISM.
THEY ARE DOING IT TO GET THEIR
POWER BACK TO ELIMINATE GAS,
OILS, COWS, PLANES AND CARS AND
EVERYTHING WILL BE FREE AND
CONFISCATE EVERYTHING EVERYBODY
MAKES.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN THIS LIKE THIS
BEFORE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RIGHT
STRATEGY IS.
BUT IF THIS IS NOT AN ABUSE OF
POWER IT SHOULD BE.
>> THEY ARE DOING IT FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS.
IF YOU WATCH CONGRESSMAN NADLER,
HE IS DENOUNCING THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
THEY ARE SAYING WE DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THAT.
WE NEED TO START OUR OWN AND
CALL IT MUD.
WE HAVE STOP CALLING THEM THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE SOCIALISTS.
THEY WANT TO TAKE OVER YOUR
HEALTHCARE.
THEY INTRODUCED MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
THEY WANT TO TAKE OVER YOUR
HOMES BY THIS NEW GREEN DEAL.
THEY CALL THEMSELVES THE
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY.
WE NEED TO CALL THEM WHAT THIS
IS.
THEY WANT TO HIDE FROM THE
SUCCESS OF THE PRESIDENT.
JUST LACK WEEK 2.6% GDP GROWTH.
THIS PRESIDENT IS IN VIETNAM FOR
DENUCLEARIZATION OF NORTH KOREA.
IN THIS COUNTRY THE POLITICS
ENDS AT THE WATER'S EDGE.
THE DISLIKE FOR THIS PRESIDENT
IS SO GREAT THEY GO AGAINST
THEIR OWN COUNTRY SAFETY AND
FREEDOM.
>> Sean: IF YOU GIVE 150-BILLION